[음악]
안녕하세요 대표님 그이 채널 보시는
분들은 대표님을 아시겠지만 간단히
자기 소개 부탁드리겠습니다 갑자기 어
저는 빌사남의 경유세 표라고 합니다
중성 빌딩을 매입이 털기에 공사까지
같이 하고 있습니다
어 지금 제가 여기 수서역에 왔는데
부산에 강의할 일이 있어서 어 좀
오게 됐습니다 지금 시간이 얼마 남지
않아 아네 알겠습니다 타야 될 거
같 지금 부산에 도착을 했고요 저희가
그 같은 건물 안에서 업무를 하긴
하지만 사실 저도 회사에서 대표님을
잘 못 뵙거나 또 바쁘셔 가지고
오랜만에 뵙는 거 같아요 그래서 잘
지내고 계신가요 여러가지 좀 많이
하고 있어 가지고 좀 바쁜데 요번
주도 오늘 이제 부산 왔고 그다음
내일 모레 대구 목요일은 약간 그
고등학생 창업 특강 저번 주에는 이제
은행이랑 저희 bsn 스터디 강의까지
해 가지고 좀 최근에 좀 이런 강연
운이라든가 이런게 좀 많아진 거
같습니다 저희가 잡지도 만들고 있는데
내년 3월 때 좀 발간할 예정이고네
잡지 내용은 이제 일반적인 그거랑 좀
다르게 진짜 중계 업체 소개 뭐 중계
업체 순위 탑 뭐 예를 들어서 중개사
뭐 그런 인터뷰도 좀 딸 예정인데
이게 흥미로운 주제들 많이 좀
정리했어요 그 얼마 전에 뉴욕에 갔을
때 그런 잡지들이 좀 많이 있더라고요
그래서 한국에도 좀 만들면 좋겠다라고
생각을 해서 바로 오자마자 이제 치사
좀 여러군데 만나가지고 최근에 컨택을
해서 아마 3월 중에 나오지 않을까
싶습니다 올해 그 빌사남 부산 지사를
설립한 걸로 알고 있거든요 설립
이유와 앞으로의 좀 방향성이 좀
궁금합니다 올해 2월 달에 이제 처음
얘기 나왔다가 이제 3월 달에 설립을
했는데 생각보다 지금 좀 성가도 있고
지금 부산에 계신 분들이 최근에 이제
서울 것도 매입을 했고 그래서 반응은
생각보다 괜찮은 거 같아요 그러고
보니 이제 올해 공인중개사 시험이
얼마 남지 않았습니다 저도 좀
궁금했었는데 대표님은
자격증을네 언제 취득을 하셨나요만으로
바뀌어 가지고 18살이 떴습니다 근데
18살의 자격증을 딸 수가 있어요
그니까 원래 이제 미성년자는 못
봤는데 네네 그때 갔다 이제 법이
바뀌는 식이었어요 나이 상관없이 딸
수 있다라고 해서 그때 이제 좀
초기에 땄던 거 같아요 그래서 아마
중국에서 그때 10대가 명 붙었었는데
그중에 한 명이 접니다 와 말도 안
되게 좀 일찍 취득을 하셨네요 부동산
일을 어떻게 이렇게 시작을 하시게
되신 건지네 이거 얘기하면 시간
짜리인데 어 저는이 업에 되게 뭔가
그런 인식 같은 것도 좀 바꾸고
싶습니다 언론 상에도 너무 좀이 직업
자체가 좀 인식이 안 좋잖아요 직업에
대한 인식을 좀 바꿀 생각도 굉장히
좀 크고 앞으로이 엽에 대해서 뭔가
좀 해야 될 일이 있다라고 하면 저는
좀 앞장서서 할 생각이고 좀 이렇게
인식을 좀 바꾸고 싶습니다 뭐 다른
나라처럼
아마 좀 우리 나라도 좀 이렇게
기업로 되지 않을까 싶어요 지금
일본이나 뭐 미국 같은 경우에도 다
이제 기업화가
됐거든요네 대표님
강의하시는게 굉장히 이제 많았던 걸로
알고 고 있는데 혹시 지금도 떨리긴
하나요 아 물론 떨리죠 아 그러세요
떨리는데 하면서 좀 긴장이 풀어지는
거 같아
아 대표님 지금 무슨 생각하세요 아무
[음악]
생 아 올라가 되게
좋다지네
시작하기 전에 어 세개를 약하게습니다
소이
그다음에는
[음악]
성가다고 수익률이 당연히 안 나오겠죠
법인들은 만약에 설립한다고 했을 때
다음 보도록 하겠습니다
[박수]
감사합니다
배님 지금 강인 끝나고 어디 가시는
아 지금 밥먹으러 가고
있습니다
인터뷰 해야
되는데 계속 전화 중이시네요
어 안녕하세요
아 오늘 강의는 어떠셨어요 괜찮았어요
괜찮았어요 연마를 좀 그 새로운 분들
좀 뽑아 가지고네 일단 10월이 또
되니 그 시험이니까 끝나고 나면 또
그래도 좀 오신 않을까 싶은데 그니까
아 그래서 진짜 사실 여기 2 30대
중개사가 이럴 회사가 없으니까 그렇죠
맞아요 네 좀 바짝 뽑아 가지고 하
요즘 문 닫는데도 많은 거 같더라고요
엄청 많아요네 공인중개사 협회에서
이렇게 개업이 폐업 이렇게 정리해
놓은 거 엑셀 파일 받았는데 장난
아니에요 지금 그 지금 버티는
업체들은 그니까 이제 작년에 제작
작년이랑 재작년에 벌어놓은 분들 아
그렇죠 쉽지 않아 응 그러니까 지금
좀 원래 컸던 중계 법인 업체들도 좀
흔들리고 있다라는 말씀이신 거죠
습니다
안녕하세요 지금 부산지사 다녀오셨는데
혹시 뭐 어떤 업무 보셨는지 이런저런
얘기 나았고 새로 오신 분 또 있어
가지고 인사도 좀 드리고 또 우연
창교 고객분을 만났는데 또 우연 창교
이제 구독자분이 그래서
또 인사도 나누고 했는데 또 미팅
있어 가지고네 또 급하게 나왔어 어딜
또 가시는 건가요 예 아 알겠습니다
그러면은 다음 또 미팅 지로 이동
이동하겠습니다 네네 대표님 지금
미팅은 또 어떤 미팅이 부산 분이
서울 거 매입하고 싶다 그래서 지금
가고 있습니다 부산 분이 서울을
매입하다 그요네 아 아 근데 부산
분이 이렇게 서울을
매입하시나요
거리가 있어서 좀 오기는 불편하긴
하지만 루트만 좀 잘 정해 주면은
충분히 살 수 있다라고 생각하거든요
그리고 또 이제 상 고객분들이 항상
살려는 니즈가 있긴 한데 그거를
뭔가이 맡아서 해 줄 업체가 좀 없긴
합니다 저희가 좀 맡아서 해 드리려고
하고 있고 더 나아가서 공사까지
맡아서 해 드리니까 더 좀 좋아하시는
거
같아요 대표님 이걸로 좀 부산 일정은
끝인가요네 뭐 끝났는데 목소리도 안
나오네요 지금 잘 아 강의 뭐 강연
뭐 손님 미팅 유튜브 촬영 등 뭐
힘들진 않으신가요 일이라고 생각 안
하고 저는 되게 재밌는 놀이라고
생각하거든요 뭐 돈 이런 거 상관없이
뭐 물론 이제 저도 경제 자유 이루지
못했지만 의미가 있는 거 같 저도
되게 좀 힘을 많이 없고 더 열심히
할 거 앞으로 더 재밌는 거 많이 할
예정입니다 이렇게 오 산한 김윤수
대표님의 일상을 좀
담아봤는데네 오늘 어떠셨나요 이게
평소 일상입니다 뭐 항상 느끼는
거지만 불러주는 거에 감사 이렇게
바쁜 거에 항상 감사해 하고 있습니다
앞으로도 좀 이렇게 재밌고 좀 바쁜
일들이 많았으면 좋겠습니다네 그래서
오늘 영상 여기까지 하고요 다음
시간에 또 뵙도록 하겠습니다
감사합니다